hi kevin o'leary your investor at large
in the most fantastic place to be in the
middle of winter turks and caicos right
on the beach and one of the premier
developments here right across the way
though is an empty derelict building
which reminds me that chaos that's
happened in real estate all through the
Caribbean and to get more on this I've
invited one of the premier developers
here and personally developed this
facility go hands aboard Rajbeer to join
me for a cocktail while we discuss money
and real estate rob somebody lost some
money right across the beach here
half-built development looks like a
sterile acquaintance yeah you know we've
been affected by the global recession
here too and some developers started and
then they saw their sales dry up and we
couldn't finish the project we were
fortunate enough here at the gansevoort
Turks and Caicos to have the financial
wherewithal to finish the project and we
open in march two thousand nine but a
lot of developers here and around the
Caribbean has been affected by the
global recession yes one of the biggest
banks in the whole Caribbean region is
scotiabank this is a big lender yeah for
real estate your sec definitely they
came out last week with earnings they
said things were flat in the Caribbean
they ask you a lot of economic activity
does that reflect on your business yeah
does it look for the next couple of
years well you know from a real estate
development standpoint yes it's flat
it's you know this
a supply of condos on the market and
houses on the market that people have
been caught by so they need to sell
those tourism remain strong and that's
that's a real positive sign in this
economy so so when they say it's flappy
mean luxury real estate what we're
starting to see an upturn imagine that
receive more more people wanting to come
to this destination because it's so
beautiful that I think it's fairly
resilient well I can attest to the
beauty and I can also test a fantastic
cocktail there until next time kevin
o'leary real estate sometimes it can
hurt